[Music]
everyone knows the harry potter universe
and besides the book series it's of
course the movies that have delighted
millions of fans around the world after
the last installment of the film series
in 2011 there were no more new screen
adventures for the titular character in
2013 wanna brothers and jk rowling got
together and decided to produce a movie
series about fantastic beasts and where
to find them following the previously
released films of 2016 and 2018 in
today's original we will discuss the
third part of the series which will be
released in theaters next year learn
everything you absolutely need to know
about fantastic beasts the secrets of
dumbledore before its release
first let's talk about the film's cast
some of the many familiar faces from the
preceding movies are of course back for
example there's eddie redmayne as newt
scamander the wizard and specialist for
magical creatures once belonged to the
hufflepuff house after leaving hogwarts
young new traveled the world in search
of his fantastic animal beasts on his
journey he meets many interesting
fellows though not all of them are well
disposed towards him also taking part in
the movie as azramila as credence
barebone credence is not only the
mysterious adopted son of the
anti-witchcraft fanatic mary lou from
part one but above all he is also an
extremely powerful wizard he has been
taken under the wing of the influential
aura percival graves but suffers from
having suppressed his magical abilities
for much of his life needless to say an
equally important character in the
upcoming film is jew law as albus
dumbledore the famous hogwarts
headmaster met his future enemy
grindelwald in godric's hollow he always
had a strong emotional bond with
grindelwald as we could clearly see in
the second installment of the fantastic
beasts series further companion of newt
is the american porpancha called tina
goldstein who's embodied by catherine
waterson the down to earth which belongs
to the house thunderbird of the elva
morning school of witchcraft and
wizardry as does her sister queenie she
and nude are quite close last but not
least we would like to introduce you to
the antagonist of the three-part film
series of course we are talking about
gellard grindelwald the notorious dark
wizard was on the run for a long time
due to various crimes he was wanted for
and is there for anything but a pleasant
contemporary especially in the second
part as the title already reveals
grindelwald's crimes are the main focus
the scene in which grindelwald
fantasizes about atomic bombs at the
second world war in a manic speech
naturally sticks in one's memory the
only ones to escape the subsequent demon
fire and paris are newt jacob kowalski
and tina who with the help of nicholas
flamel prevent the entire city from
being burned to the ground much more
troublesome than the fire was the
casting of the villain for part 3
however after the character was superbly
embodied by johnny depp in the first two
movies he was no longer an option for
warner brothers due to the notorious
lawsuit against him in november 2020 his
official departure followed after
negative reports about him kept piling
up and the film company saw no other
solution than to dismiss johnny depp
this is precisely what many movie fans
criticized warner for since his ex-wife
amber heard has since also been noticed
for defamation and false statements
against them so now an appropriate
replacement had to be found quickly as
filming a fantastic beast the secret of
dumbledore was about do after short but
intensive search they finally introduced
matt mikkelsen as the new gala
grindelwald the dane is not a bad choice
given that he was convincing with his
acting skills as a villain in the
hannibal series for example
behind the scenes the company is
operating according to the idiom never
change a winning team and is relying on
david yates as director the 57 year old
britain established his reputation above
all with the production of the last four
harry potter films after all he made a
significant contribution to their
success as director yates was equally in
charge of the first two fantastic beasts
movies the screenplay was not penned by
an unknown author from hollywood either
but by harry potter creator and
best-selling author jk rowling according
to kevin sushihara the president of
warner brothers at the time rowling
worked extremely hard on the script so
that it would turn out even better than
its predecessors shooting was supposed
to start in the summer of 2019 but was
then moved to february 2020 in favor of
better pre-production since the film is
supposed to be bigger and even better
than its preceding titles the actual
start of filming was then not until
september 2020 due to the pandemic and
after brief hiatus due to a case of
infection it was finally completed in
may 2021 a lot of the not so well-known
members of the crew such as said
designer stuart craig were also already
involved in the harry potter series and
sadly ensure the proper atmosphere
let's now move on to the possible plot
of fantastic beasts the secrets of
dumbledore first of all let's take a
look at the story of the two prequels to
refresh your memory in the first part we
see nude arriving in new york city in
1926 with a suitcase in it are of course
all sorts of little animals that he
managed to find on his journey such as a
niffler and his boat truckles we quickly
realized that the mood is very tense in
the city as more and more prejudice and
hostility from the population is
building up against the secretly
operating magical society things get
even worse when mario jacob kowalski
accidentally opens nude suitcase causing
some of the animals to escape as a
result he ensures that chaos takes its
course as they try to recapture the
animals together with two witch sisters
they must face some dangerous opponents
the plot of the second part picks up
more or less directly from the first one
but as the title already reveals it is
particularly centered on the villain
grindelwald the dark wizard's ambitious
goal is to control the muggles through
pure blood wizards these plans soon
become serious when grindelwald with the
help of machus abernathy manages to
escape during a prisoner transport and
quickly gathers a considerable number of
followers newt is eventually contacted
by albus dumbledore and asked to attend
to the matter and thwart grindelwald's
plans in paris by the way the second
part did not really generate much
enthusiasm among the fan community and
apart from a convincing performance by
johnny depp will definitely not go down
in film history so unlike the first part
which was mostly well received many seem
to perceive fantastic beasts the crimes
of grindelwald as a downgrade this makes
the way for fantastic beasts the secret
of dumbledore all the more exciting
since warner and the team seem to be
doing everything in their power to make
the third part more elaborate and epic
fittingly warner ceo kevin sujihara also
spoke out in an interview with the los
angeles times in 2019 in which he
clarified that the second part didn't do
so well and that everything must be done
to make the third movie even better than
the first still can anyone even suspect
what jk rowling and writing partner
steve cloves have put on paper and all
this time incidentally the latter was
also involved in the scripts for almost
all the harry potter films but anyway so
far there are no exact details about the
story but it seems that the story of
newt will not be over after the third
part it has always been clear that the
movie series would end up consisting of
five parts culminating in the big
showdown between albus dumbledore and
his former friend gallagh grindelwald in
1945 accordingly fantastic beasts the
secrets of dumbledore would be the
midpoint of the story arc and as we
already know from a 2018 tweet from
rowling the journey in the upcoming film
will take us to far away rio de janeiro
for die hard fans of the harry potter
universe this of course rings a bell
after all the wizarding school castelo
bruxo is also located in brazil which
could be highlighted in more detail
accordingly dumbledore as the title
suggests is also expected to become more
of a focal point thus it could be about
dumbledore having been involved in
grindelwald's plans for the greater good
and even having forged those plans with
him as a youth the secrets of dumbledore
could likewise mean the secrets of the
dumbledore family but that's pure
speculation so far news actor dan fogler
who embodies the aforementioned jacob
kowalski has obviously long been allowed
to read through the script and concludes
that one can expect a delightful
character development similar to the
first film he also notes the oppressive
mood in the film which later leads to
world war ii and last but not least
notes that you can look forward to epic
battles sounds quite exciting so far
don't you think there are still many
unanswered questions for instance
whether queenie will continue to be
follower of grindelwald or how credence
will deal with the fact that he's in
truth orel is dumbledore and does the
long lost brother of albus dumbledore it
remains exciting and we can only hope
that warner brothers will soon release a
first teaser that will shorten the
waiting time until the release on april
15th
2022
and that's it for our latest original
did you like our preview of fantastic
beasts the secrets of dumbledore if so
please give the video a thumbs up and
hit the subscribe button also do you
have any other ideas or speculations
about what the story of the third
installment might look like let us know
in the comments see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you